fried cheese sweet onions that's not
allow me everything mixed in one all I'm
julissa you also got the in today's
Dominican Independence Day and we are
cooking up mangu Colo tray golpes yes
girl yeah
mangu con los tres Gold faces mashed
plantains with the three hidden which is
fried cheese fried salami and fried eggs
you can have mango for lunch for dinner
it honestly is whenever you want to have
it but it's traditionally a breakfast
well you need to do is grab the platinum
you peel them like I'm doing right here
because I'm a beast of course it's like
some of them twice because they cook a
lot faster being Dominican means loving
on other people and specifically making
other people laugh if you have three
Dominicans in the room you're gonna have
a party Thanksgiving turns into a party
a funeral turns into a party a movie
night turns into a party one person puts
bachata and that's it and then with my
cheese I put that into flour not
everybody uses flour I will tell you
that but that's how my mom taught me and
then I fry them in hot oil make sure
that the oil is scorching hot when it
starts to puff up on top that's when you
know they're ready to be flipped and you
see that they're golden brown and the
cheese is the first to go cuz it's so
good we have three different types of
salami and each salami taste different
this is how you cook a salami right here
whoo mmm
growing up every Saturday morning I will
wake up to mommy in the kitchen and the
whole house smell like fried salami and
those vinegar soaked onions look at the
brightness look at the pink in it do you
smell the vinegar it like wakes you up
and like smacks you in the face and it
allows you to be like today it's gonna
be a great day
so grab the fluff and I'll put it in a
separate Bowl pour some leftover caldo
on top then add some butter but a lot
put a little bit I don't give it that
it's whatever you like hey I found where
they smash it up until this night
smooth then a salami oil onion vinegar
everybody has their own way of doing it
the platano that we're eating is african
hmm that's why they're so damn good we
are after all a team mm-hmm there is
beauty in our melanin we are amazing
Dominicans have the best of both worlds
yes we're Latinos but we're also black
and that makes us that much doper I love
that that was beautiful you don't even
need me to say anything I know I never I
just hope you guys enjoyed this as much
as we enjoy you're welcome something oh
oh yes
happy Dominican Independence they are